hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to papers please
i thought of this game because i
recently went over to canada which
required me to go over the border
crossing and because of kofi 19 it's a
lot more complicated than it used to be
you can skip over the story if you'd
like but it is really fascinating to see
the inner workings of how the
immigration service works
during a time when there need to be the
quarantine things and you need a lot of
paperwork you need everything in
in in perfect working order else they're
gonna send you back home
so funny story about coming to canada is
uh you need a lot of things you need
number one
because i'm not a canadian citizen i
need a valid work permit but i could not
pick up the work permit until i
got to canada so i needed to pick it up
from the immigration office and when i
got to the immigration office i needed a
lot of paperwork already done
i need to have an exact plan of what i
was going to do to quarantine
where i was going to quarantine how i
was going to quarantine how i was going
to get food when i quarantined and where
i was going afterwards and then i needed
to provide justification for the work
permit and then i needed to pay for the
work permit
then and there couldn't do it in advance
so it was a lot of things that needed to
be done in order to get me into canada
to be perfectly honest
i had to take a test within three days
of arriving i had to take a test
when i arrived in canada and then i had
to take a test eight
days after i arrived in canada when i
was quarantining and that actually
changed because it was 10
was brought down to eight and there was
some difference in terms of when people
thought that i needed to do that so a
lot of complications so i'm gonna play
papers please because this is
what i believe to be marginally less
complicated than what i
just went through to get here plus i
played that knockoff version of papers
please
and uh that was crap but this is
apparently a very good game i have
dabbled in it myself i've never played
it to completion i've never done a video
of it so i thought it was about a good
time to do it myself
nudity no thank you an easy mode
not for me please all right let's get
this done
congratulations yada yada the october
labor lottery is complete your name was
pulled
for immediate placement report to the
ministry of admission at greston border
checkpoint uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
an apartment will be provided for you
and your family in the east grestin
expect class eight dwelling uh-huh
uh-huh uh-huh glory to arstotzka
yes i to any position stamp passport
entry vision return document center and
gender
is restricted to our satoshi citizens
only to deny all foreigners okay
let's give this a go shall we hi hey
finally you can return home you sure can
alright you look good to me
kabuski there you go good job thanks bud
thank you have a good one next please oh
sorry
sorry yeah uh sorry you can't no
are still skins only yeah sorry hey
what's up hey what's up hey how you
doing oh
man i would love to but unfortunately no
eight hours that sucks uh well hopefully
it'll be quicker going home
hi this is artistoska yeah it is
yeah it is welcome home welcome home hey
how you doing buddy
nice sweater love the turtleneck it's a
mistake to open
all right buddy hi how you doing ah this
looks good this looks good
the picture looks good hey thanks keep
it up
keep it up hell hi my what
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah whoo
who the fricker is this right
no no that's not you is that you just
different
hair was that you with just different
hair oh
but it looked different but it looked
different
okay so apparently it's i'm looking into
it too much i'm too smart
for this apparently hey okay
hey what's up hey welcome home yeah okay
slam this on there get out of my face
all right well i only got a warning so i
didn't get any penalties so i guess it's
fine
whatever all right oh wow that's
expensive
all right okay but my savings has
technically gone
up do we really need food or heat is
that something that's
necessary what if we do a little less
food than we would usually do
might be a good strategy probably not
rest in checkpoint a success
entry restrictions to relax admit
foreigners analysts upbeat increased
trade and cooperation predicted
i'm sure that's all gonna go
exceptionally let's get to work
everybody get in get in go go go oh god
what was that wait wait
wait wait wait inspection hardware check
carefully discrepancies any entrance
with inconsistent information will be
denied you look good to me
how do i how do i tell
no correlation matching data okay looks
good to me
looks good to me bud it looks good to me
have a good one hey how's it going you
look fine to me i don't even need to
check
i know you're good i know you're good
what no
invalid expiration date hello expiration
date
uh let's see
all right we're good here you look good
to me look good i trust you
get out of here buddy what did i do
wrong invalid issuing city last warning
oh
god i'm sorry hey how you doing hey
what's up oh yeah
oh yeah i'm meeting a bus soon well you
know what
there you go you're not gonna miss it
this time you're not gonna miss it this
time
did i mention that i'm not very good at
this game okay um
inspect uh this sure
uh how am i supposed to know the issuing
city what would i what would i even know
what would i what do i what would
matching data okay it's fine you're fine
you look good to me
god this is going to get stressful real
quick hello
hello handsome hey what's up how you
know
if you want a good time come to oh hey
wow
yeah i mean i went to before
yeah i went to before yeah you know
hey you know
anyway what is up oh wait a minute
what's going on here
what is this all about discrepancy
hey oh hey wait a minute
hey what oh no
oh no oh god
you might wanted to have a shooted
earlier
oh boy the day was cut short by a
terrorist attack progress is saved at
the start of each
my savings i only got 20 dollars
oh i'm such a garbage heap i'm gonna die
i'm gonna die god damn it i'm gonna die
terrorist strike aggression
checkpoint lockdown more guards more
scrutiny man i'm gonna have to memorize
a
lot of information to make sure this
goes down oh
boy i am here what was this okay all
foreigners entry ticket okay entry
ticket got it
got it okay uh entry ticket this looks
good
is the valid on this state is this good
okay this looks good to me looks good to
me
uh you got it there you go here you go
cause no trouble no trouble at all zero
trouble please alright what do we got
you look good wes
grestin um oh looks
wait no uh oh nope you don't have an
entry ticket
wait no oh oh [ __ ] well should i have
asked oh god
you where's your entry ticket you didn't
have one didn't have one doesn't matter
i can't even ask him where it was he
didn't have one hey there
happy you could make it oh wow
yeah you know i got one of those before
but uh you know hey you know what you go
you go ahead you know you go ahead maybe
i'll catch you later i mean i wait no
i'm a married man i'm a married man i
can't
can't be doing any of that ah you know
okay i'm starting to get an idea
of the exact type of information that i
need to put forward
okay heard about the terrorist attack
lucky to have a job so well you're lucky
to get inside
congratulations be safe okay you don't
need an entry ticket because you're not
a
foreigner you are an or stolskin
aristoskin national probably doesn't
need one
hey it's this dude hey how you doing
buddy
uh my dude uh my main man my
inspect mode to interrogate
where's your passport buddy
hmm yeah okay good luck good luck pal
thanks for wasting so much time my
family's gonna starve because of you but
i appreciate
appreciate it hey bud how are you doing
nope where's your entry ticket
get out of here i'm paid money based on
how many people i go through but i don't
know if it's whether people are actually
getting through or if it's just people
that i talk to hey bud how you doing
this looks good to me
[Music]
maybe probably is what no it's all
gender
oh how dare you you don't know that
you don't know this wrong date get out
of here
get out of here papers please thank you
okay uh looks good to me
thank you when i can get one more i can
get two more i can get two more done all
right what do we got here
that looks good this looks good all
looks good looks good to me
let's do another let's do another come
on come on i can make the money
why no no invalid issuing city how do i
know how would you know what do you know
the cities
i don't know what the cities are these
are how am i supposed to know what the
cities are
where does it say the cities it's like a
oh my god non-matching photo it looked
good to me it looked fine
do i have to go study the cities am i
gonna actually have to learn
what the cities are am i gonna have to
actually look at this and be
completely understanding of all the
cities oh cue the epic
study montage
all right this is gonna be tough i can
tell that this is going to be a little
bit difficult
oh my god how in the hell
how in the flip flap in hell
how in the ass blasting hell am i
supposed to know about
that how in the heck
united federation impor kalechia
arstoska these are the seven countries
how the hell am i supposed to our stoze
discretes are as follows out then for
silhouette
burton octvallis genestore landed former
levels and fell
far desto issuing cities are separate
from those
or backbone or east christian power
[Music]
all right you know what i'm gonna do you
know i'm not [ __ ] around here i'm not
i'm not around i'm not gonna [ __ ] around
not okay all right
you know what this is it's an ipad so
i'm willing to bet that there's a
quick reference guide right perfect
perfect okay so i gotta find the one
that's perfectly
oh that's good you know what i have here
bam
you probably can't see that very good
but that is a cheat sheet
that's a cheat sheet right so this is
going to help me because this means that
i'm going to be able to know exactly
what's supposed to go where and no one's
going to be able to pull a fast one on
me
because i'm a freaking genius i wonder
if the clock doesn't start until
absolutely
i call in the first person is that true
okay it doesn't okay our sourcing
citizens must show their id card
foreigners must secure and present a
valid entry permit okay entry tickets
are no longer sufficient new chapter
detailing documents featured have been
added to your rulebook check all
information thoroughly deny any
applicants with discrepant documents
refer to the audio transcript correlate
entrance statements
all right glory to arstoska
let's get it gone baby it's time give me
your papers okay
so we got this okay it's got a good seal
the date
okay enter by is good i remain for 60
days two months
that's good okay united federation
shingleton
all this is looking very good for you
very good this looks great this looks
all looks very good
thank you for that thank you thank you
for having all your paperwork in order
and ready to go
papers please hi republia huh
transit okay duration of stay a couple
weeks that's two weeks okay
dates good dates good here republia
boston very good very good sir you've
got it all ready to go i appreciate that
all right who we got hello how are you
purpose of your visit uh oh
get out get out get out get
out get out get out get out
hi welcome purpose of your trip visit
six months stay okay all looks good
you got from impor okay hey han this
looks good to me
oh it's good you go see your son wait
yeah you go see your son have a good day
you take care of yourself and you take
care of that son of yours you take care
of that
hey have a good one hey you take care
now you take care now you take care now
you dig there now you take care now you
take care now
invalid id number and valid id number
hey weeks okay passport number okay that
passport number max
works two months good date oh god oh
god okay good i guess i don't know
i don't know ah
what did i do in valid name oh my god
hi dude what is this
what is what is this what is
this this is this is this is terrible
this is awful no
cobra stun
hi hello
id card okay arstoszka we got
from okay the weights good all
tan good looks good
eleanor okay good all looks good welcome
home
oh this is so hard why is this so hard
why is this so no no no you don't know
that god damn it damn you
okay good fisher alec
great burnton that's a district okay
burton's good
okay this looks good to me looks good to
me get on
out of here buddy get on out and go home
see your family
don't give me a ticket okay
why in valid height you are joking me
i have to look at the height maybe he
was wearing
shoes i don't know
okay visiting first day
two months nicolette dates good dates
good hey
han we got impor hey hans good
looks good to me you know it's good
you're good
get out of here get out of here you're
good
uh of visit immigrating
okay passport's good the dates good
forever
okay great right united federation great
rapid that's good
name matches number matches it all looks
good to me
looks good to me congratulations you
made it in you're moving here forever
oh no it wasn't in valid x3 but it
wasn't but it wasn't
was it was it i don't know was it oh
god i know it looks good republia boston
it looks good to me the date looks good
my brother
papers please purposely immigrating
forever
okay okay this date is bad okay i can
see that straight up that date's bad
get out of here you're not living here
not if i have anything to say about it
and i
do the rent has gone up why has the rent
gone up
but my family's not dead yet so i'm
going to bet
until they're dead republian track star
wanted for
murder vince lostradaes am i gonna have
to find this dude
okay i now need to detain suspicious
individuals because
that's my job now okay yeah let's get it
god let's do this gang let's do this hey
i'm ready
papers blows purpose
visit okay nah no these these don't
match up
get out of here get the [ __ ] out of here
i forget what the dude i needed to rest
looks like so
that's not gonna why wait a minute
lestrade
oh my god i've got him guys we got him
guys we got him are you vince lestrade
damn look i did not kill her do not
believe the republian lies
detain look not my job dude not my job
you guys to go
yep next buddy got him we got him guys
we got him
we got him hi what's up hey welcome
don't don't mind all that
jazz that happened before okay date is
good two weeks okay that's good
name is good passport numbers
good pictures good antegria
which is hi-ha oh
my dude my main man you are denied
get out of here i don't even need to
check i don't even need to check
i know that's the wrong issuing city
because i have a cheat sheet up here
[ __ ] okay i'm on a roll now i'm
gonna roll
purpose of your visit passing through 14
days
name matches up date is good passport
number's good the united federation
chorus to city is good expiration on
that city
names good all good there okay good good
good we're good
beautiful day finally free from
antiquing tyranny immigrate forever
well let's see about that pal let's see
about that your date's okay
expiration here is good and
okay well today seems to be your lucky
day everything is actually in an order
which is uh a shocking to me
but uh hey everything looks good to me
hey take care you have a great day
kind of my uh oh oh no oh god no
yeah your husband made it through um
let's see uh sorry
this no
where's your entry permit please beg you
they would not give me a permit i had no
choice
i will be killed well you know you're
lucky because i've actually been on a
good roll so uh i'm just gonna give you
the go ahead here and i'm gonna let you
through you have a good one hey enjoy
enjoy your life with your husband you
will not forget oh
look at that that's so nice oh look at
that
yeah whatever whatever warning i can
take that
wherever is your visit work oh well that
ain't right
nah get out of here look i did a favor
to someone else i'm not gonna do a favor
for you
look at this thing that's pretty cool
this is going great
i suddenly got very good at this game
all of a sudden
visit dates good dates good numbers
match up
name matches up uh oh oh oh well look
i'm not the judge of this
um but uh listen
it says on it why well look i uh
yeah well look i look it's
look all right look look look look look
look at me why are you looking at me
hey bud have a nice stash
what are we looking at here 85 179 that
looks good
birthday name matches up tavalius that's
good our extrovert
sure good uh oh buddy
right it's expired my dude it's expired
my dude
dude it's expired my dude get me get on
the winning
[Applause]
booth upgrade space to toggle the
inspect mode oh hell yeah
oh hell yeah upgrade the booth oh give
me that upgrade
oh hell yeah dude i'm doing good hey
you're cold
whatever you're gonna be warm tonight so
shut up i ain't dealing in penalties
anymore
i'm freaking bawling i'm bawling out my
ass
all right well that's good i got a booth
upgrade jobs few
becoming fewer immigrants taking jobs
from locals vince lestrade
apprehended in greston track champ looks
quite guilty now
well maybe he is maybe he is who am i to
judge right who am i to judge
all right let's get through one more day
one more perfect day one more perfect
ministry of labor has instituted a
special program to control
immigrant later travels for entering for
work require a valid work
pass okay work requires work pass
got it okay work pass plan to work
okay work 12 weeks okay architecture
it's got a thing the date's good the
dates good
the dates good the numbers match the
name matches
united federation great rapid this is
all good surprisingly
you did it buddy hey congratulations you
actually made it through the complicated
process
i'm very proud of you very proud of you
all right papers plus
okay work great
it's work a year okay here
oh hey that kind of work huh food
service okay
dates good dates good there dates good
here numbers match up there alberstan
mergeris shockingly once again
looks like everything's actually in
order which i am
greatly surprised by thank you for the
card by the way
hmm my man named davi
lana promised me and my sister working i
do not trust him i'm afraid he will take
my passport and force me to work with
brah he's in line
okay danny luddem okay looking for a
danny luddum
okay two weeks dates a good date's
good this does not line up sorry buddy
you guys to go get out of the get the
freak out
i don't know if i should be
interrogating people but if i see the
discrepancy right away i'm not even
gonna bother
visit numbers line up dates good dates
good
30 days oh what did you just say to me
what the frick did you just say to me
buddy what what did you just say
length of your stay is different well i
guess that's fine
you just said the wrong thing all right
whatever
that's what i mean
right hey what's up buddy
oh god i'm sorry pal look
you need an entry permit menu funny guy
look look my dude i hate to say it but
you uh you it no yeah very strict yeah
okay cool good hell have a good one
all right later my dude hey what's up
nice stash
immigrating okay numbers match dates
good
dates good uh look i hate to ask this
but um the passport is correct
yeah you know i can't i can't deny that
i can't deny that i can't deny that
can't deny that passport is correct
whatever you say my dude hey
what is what he said he's what he said
that's what he said
oh oh loot him
i'll loot him okay loot him uh well the
thing is um
it says you're 180 centimeters but by
the tippy toppy of your hair that's
actually kind of
wrong also uh you're uh burton
i uh man i don't think i don't think so
man
look i don't think so i i i don't think
so man i look i can't
i can't do that yeah sorry bro i i just
couldn't
bring yeah no
well how'd you know if he was cleared
for entry whatever couple days
date is good date is good fedorkalechia
the door that's good okay
shockingly you go hey pal
sports huh job
one month number is good dates good it's
good
uh impor hey hans whoa
oh [ __ ]
was i supposed to know something about
that was that supposed to be more
obvious than it was
all right well i think i'm going to end
this here this game is a lot more
tough dancers at greston club found dead
but i didn't let them
through but when i went to the main
crescent club oh my god
oh right this is a lot tougher than i
thought it'd be
it's a lot tougher than i thought it'd
be it was a lot lot tougher than i
thought it'd be
but i'm going to continue this later and
i'm going to hopefully not
kill as many people as i have been
including my family i would hope that i
don't kill them anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down the
comments below and if you enjoyed it let
me know
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye bye
oh for the next video you're gonna need
a work permit and an entry visa so uh
make sure you have those ready before
you watch the video because i will be
checking and if you aren't
like up to date on your documents you
won't be allowed to watch the video
okay bye
[Music]
you